we're all told of course the debate is
over and that all the sign
agree I'd like to call this the
Emperor's new
and as all of you know that is simply
not the case
but now I'd like to address myself to a
serious and grim subject and that is the
actual threat that global warming poses
to our planet and most specifically to
California and that is a very real and
devastating one I speak specifically of
the radical policies that the global war
mongers are now enacting in the summer
of 2006 in the name of saving the planet
from global warming California adopted
the most radically restrictive
legislation anywhere on the planet
included a b32 which requires a 25%
reduction in man-made carbon dioxide
emissions by the year 2020 now to put
this in perspective we could junk every
car in the state of California right now
and not meet that mandate at about the
same time the same politicians who
adopted these measures also adopted 40
billion dollars of bonds that they
promised would be used for highways dams
aqueducts and other capital improvements
now here's the problem building highways
and dams and aqueducts requires
tremendous amounts of cement how cement
produced while it's produced by taking
limestone and superheating it into a
molten state it comes out the other side
is a compound called clinker clinkers
about two-thirds the weight of the
original limestone the missing third of
that weight is carbon dioxide and when
you include the emissions required to
superheat the limestone it turns out
that for every ton of cement a ton of
carbon dioxide is released it's the
third biggest source of carbon dioxide
in all human enterprise but now we have
a law that specifically forbids us from
doing so that was the essence of the
lawsuits that were filed against
construction projects and are being
filed against construction projects
across our state so construction is
history agriculture is in big trouble
too in agriculture as California's
number one industry you can start with
nitrogen fertilizer which is a critical
component of all Agricole
full activity unfortunately it produces
large amounts of nitrous oxide another
so-called greenhouse gas that has to be
radically curtailed in California the
wine industry is also in for a shock
fermentation of wine occurs when a
molecule of glucose and the grapes is
converted into equal parts of alcohol
and carbon dioxide and the the biggest
agricultural impact is our state
administration's mandate for heavily
subsidized use of ethanol fuel ethanol
is produced exactly the same way as
alcohol and wine the glucose in corn is
converted into equal parts of ethyl
alcohol and carbon dioxide following
ab32 this administration imposed
requirement that all gasoline sold in
California by next year must be
comprised of at least 10% ethanol which
doubles the current mandate now any of
you who brought pocket calculators pull
them out and walk through this with me
one acre of corn produces about 350
gallons of ethanol there are 15 billion
gallons of gasoline used in California
each year so in order to meet the 10
percent requirement in three years it
means converting 4.3 million acres of
farmland to ethanol production now
that's a lot of farmland considering we
only have 11 million of acres of
producing crops of any kind in
California so the current ethanol
mandates are already producing serious
shortages in other parts of the world as
farmland that had been producing food
shifts to ethanol to chase hundreds of
millions of dollars of government
subsidies that are coming out of our
pockets and we're seeing this across the
board and as you see your grocery prices
rise as a result of this policy I'll
just be glad you're not in the third
world food is still a relatively small
portion of family incomes and affluent
nations it consumes more than half of
earnings in third-world countries so
when the global warming alarmists
predict worldwide starvation there right
there causing it electricity prices are
also taking a heavy hit California
already suffers the highest electricity
prices in the continental United States
and that situations about to get worse
a companion measure to ab32 was SB 13 68
that prohibits the importation of
electricity produced by coal even
state-of-the-art EPA approved power
plants thousands of miles from
California Truckee became the first
victim of this law my truck he was about
to sign a 50 year contract for
electricity produced by a new coal-fired
plant in the state of Utah they were
forced to back off because of this
legislation now the original contract
was for $35 per megawatt hour the green
replacement power will cost Truckee
consumers $65 per megawatt hour there's
one other thing that strikes me on this
issue and that's how puny is the amount
of carbon dioxide produced by human
enterprise compared to simple natural
processes the ab32 mandate is to reduce
man-made carbon dioxide emissions in
California by a hundred and seventy
million metric tons per year that's what
all of this tremendous economic
dislocation is about now let me mention
one other man-made source of carbon
dioxide that they don't count every one
of us in this room will produce about
2.2 pounds of carbon dioxide today by
deliberately willfully breathing now
again pull out those pocket calculators
that's 800 pounds of carbon dioxide each
year there are 6.6 billion of us on this
planet that comes to 5.3 trillion pounds
or 2.4 billion metric tons of carbon
dioxide simply through the process of
human respiration and that's before you
add in all the cats and rats and
elephants around the world so there 2.4
billion tons of carbon dioxide emissions
worldwide by human breathing
and 170 million metric tons is what all
the fuss is about in California the
Obama administration's just unveiled its
budget a three point six trillion dollar
monstrosity that includes some six
hundred and fifty billion dollars in
business taxes they call it cap and
trade but what they really mean is cap
and tax the the problem of course with
business taxes is that businesses don't
pay them business taxes can only be paid
in one of three ways business taxes are
either paid by us as consumers through
higher prices by us as employees through
lower wages or by us as investors
through lower earnings mainly on what's
left of our 401ks and the president's
cap and tax plan is going to cost about
$2,100 for every man woman and child in
our nation or about eighty four hundred
dollars directly out of the purchasing
power of an average family of four in
the worst economy in a generation you
know in normal times people don't pay a
lot of attention to public policy that's
why democracies occasionally drift off
course but when a crisis approaches
that's when you see a democracy engage
one by one
citizens sense the approach of a common
danger and they rise to the occasion
they focus they look beyond the symbols
and the rhetoric and they begin to make
very good decisions political majorities
can shift very quickly in such times
polls can reverse themselves almost
overnight in such times and I don't
believe that that day is rapidly
approaching the radical policies now
imposed on California are taking a
dreadful toll on its economy and will
become ever more dire in the days ahead
as the impact of these policies is felt
people will begin paying close attention
to public policymaking and the
policymakers responsible and then
they'll begin exercising something that
the majority of California's public
officials have so completely lacked
simple common sense Abraham Lincoln put
it this way he said if the voters get
their backsides too close to the fire
they'll just have to sit on the blisters
for a while our nation's got some very
painful blisters to sit on
for a while but in the process because
of organizations like Heartland like
cooler ages ancient mariner the satyr
but a wiser nation will wake tomorrow
morn thank you very much